including a chance to be involved in the  slam dunk contest text tonight's code  dunk to five five six seven eight to  enter  and you could win don't forget to watch  game four saturday at nine  eastern on espn for another chance well  this young man when he was drafted out  of north carolina they said  best shooter in the draft he's so much  more than just a shooter  [Applause]  paul george gets it off in time oh he  banks it in  it's good paul george at the buzzer  1.1 on the inbound from half court  clearly gets it off too no doubt about  it  we head to the fourth quarter clippers  up by 11.  it goes  that's why you see me walk around like  nothing's bothering me  hit me  [Applause]  [Music]  is  [Music]  [Music]  bugatti